superhero movies might not have been all
that popular in the 90s but they were at
least more popular than superhero
parodies with that in mind Mystery Men
never really had a chance still people
who slept on the film missed an
endearing superhero story with one of
the strangest casts ever assembled Ben
Stiller William H Macy Tom Waits Eddie
Izzard Paul Rubens Hank Azaria and a
Michael Bay Cameo it's a
quintessentially 90s movie complete with
a Dane Cook sighting and a music video
tie-in to smash mouth's All-Star with
the current glut of superhero movies
it's a delight watching The Misfits of
Mystery Men fumble around with their
mostly useless superpowers you can't
throw a knife sometimes
you can't use a rake sometimes well I'm
the blue launcher I'm not a stab man in
fact many of the jokes in the film have
actually improved with h